it's a lovely construction yep rook and
Shuffle G3 E3 G3 the king is permanently
cut off and there most importantly
there's no zuzvong because the Rook has
two possible squares
yes exactly close your eyes a monkey
could draw this and I think La Quang
will give up the draw very shortly
yeah we can see on his body language
he's very disappointed because there are
some positions you can squeeze and you
can hope for something but here he knows
exactly that that's it it's over
such a good feeling a response must be
experiencing right now he just knows
that this is a theoretical draw and he
doesn't have to think
or do anything you just go rookie
through Rook G3 you respond to checks
and that's it like Huang acquiesces to
the drop one of Mario of advances what a
save